going into debt to gain education
fundamentally makes sense it's got to be
the right education that can make you
money you got to get a return on it yeah
Elon was saying something about how
neuralink in the future it's going to be
such a competitive advantage that they
could price it at whatever they want
because once you have it you'll be so
much more able than anyone who doesn't
have it that you could so easily pay off
the price of the thing that's how it
should work conceptually this is the
simplest example that I have so A friend
of mine has a 17 year old daughter she
got a job at a bowling alley and she
makes minimum wage he said why don't you
become a phlebotomist he was like well I
don't want to spend the money it's like
it's 500 bucks and it's a two-day
certification and then after you have
that you make 25 an hour she didn't have
the money now she could save it to get
the 500 or she could take a loan for the
500 bucks and pay back in a week right
because she has higher earning capacity
she could either save for eight weeks
from her her bowling alley or she could
take a loan for the 500 do the two days
and then pay it off in a week at that
one week she now has seven more weeks of
earning capacity at her new level and
she'd be net positive on the next seven
weeks of earning right and so that's
just a micro example of like what skill
investing does